yes okay this isn't my question but
um
why should
it's a question on modesty
why should women wear skirts and dresses
and can you show from the bible and also
spiritual prophecy as well why should
women wear skirts and dresses
all right
modesty
is a is a difficult concept to define in
precise terms because modesty varies
from culture to culture
i've been to india
on a couple of occasions
an indian lady may come into church and
all of this is exposed
but that's modest
in india
that's not bodis in little rock are you
following me
so don't tell me i saw a woman no no no
that's modest in india i was in ghana
and there was a guy on the pulpit
he seemed to be wrapped in a bed sheet
it wasn't a bed sheet but it looked just
wrap this around and and hit most of
this out and
but that's modest
in ghana
and so modesty depends on where you are
but there is a unifying theme regarding
modesty and that theme is the holy
spirit of god
the spirit of god will guide and you see
the church cannot provide microscopic
guidance in every little detail of the
believer's life there must be room for
the spirit of god to say don't do that
don't do that don't do that
and so what i recommend to you is you
ask
last night i said
everything must be done for the glory of
god
before you dress
before your bias outfit dress pants
whatever shoes
before you go to the barber for a
hairstyle you ladies men to
ask god
father is this for your glory
if it's not
keep waiting for the spirit to convict
you i was in namibia
and i was talking to young people one
sunday morning
and i stressed the principle of for the
glory of god without exception where you
dress your hair your shoes your
relationships your foo every single
thing
will this glorify god and it was a young
lady present
she had a
hairstyle
i mean this thing was huge
i like to call it an eagle's nest
sitting on her head that's the way it
looked
and i said okay all right next morning i
was doing one-to-one counseling and she
came and i didn't recognize her
she said you recognize me i said no she
said i am the lady who had this oh i
said what happened she said as i
listened to you
i was convicted because i realized i did
not make this choice for the glory of
god
i was simply following
fashion
and she cut it off the very day
went off into canvassing i mean just a
conviction on hairstyle took her into
canvassing and medical missionary work
she was convicted i was in bermuda
conducting weaker prayer and this guy
came every day he's a rastafarian
he has these dreadlocks and you know
this
okay
and jesus died for the whole world not
just for people were short here or
nowhere and so he came he came
the sabbath morning for baptism he went
to the back of the church
and came back and nobody recognized him
he had brought his scissors to church
with him
something in the week of prayer
convicted this man he cut the whole
thing off
because he knew honestly
that this was not for god's glory let me
tell you what's missing in many of our
decisions honesty
we will not be honest with ourselves i
chose that shoe because i want to look
good i was not thinking of god's glory
at
all
let me tell you this guaranteed if you
ask first
is this for the glory of god
your choices will change all of this
about modesty modesty will be directed
by the spirit of god as you give
yourself to christ and allow him to
direct your choices whether it's a tie
or sure
i'm not an example of anything but let
me tell you
because i travel a lot
i'm always on planes
aloe said to the preacher when the
preachers get up in a public show wear a
dark suit
because you make an effect even before
you open your mouth
you have an effect on people she said
let the effect be positive by the way
you look and all experts in psychology
will agree with that now
and so i would ask god father
what time should i wear
on the plane
literally
so i asked my wife which tie
i've stood in a bathroom with two or
three ties in my face said father which
one i've actually had ties on and then
taking them off because the spirit said
not that one
this one
that time may turn somebody off
literally
and so i ask
when i began doing that you will not
believe the thing the experiences i have
had
when i started asking god what shirt to
wear
and what tie
and what suit
i would ask him
now i can't say i heard a voice
but you get impressions
i was uh leaving i think it was nigeria
these things actually began happening to
me
and i'm coming down with my little
handbag dressed
and the immigration guy saw me coming he
said come bishop come
so i said to him when i got to the desk
why do you call me bishop
he said it's obvious you're a preacher i
said why do you say that he said the
anointing is all over you
and he took off his cap he said bless me
and so i dropped a blessing on him you
see
i was in south africa
these things began to happen and there i
was coming again through security and
the guy said to me come preacher
when i got to myself why'd you call me
priest he said but you look like one
i said okay then i went to another
officer a little further down because
you have multiple security checks he
said come come preacher he didn't hear
my first interaction i said why do you
call me preach he said but you look like
one
said okay i was another trip to south
africa i was going to a canvas a
university campus to preach the students
university of waters ran outside
johannesburg in johannesburg we were
driving my drive and i and i told him
pull in by that gas station i wanted
some gum you know americans love chewing
gum
so he pulled in and i went to one little
store like a 7-eleven and i said do you
have gum she said uh yes
he gave me the gum i said you have juice
she said no
so i got the juice
no i asked her for juice first with
juice
she went to get the juice and the juice
was
right next to the liquor
so i said uh you were close to the
liquor section is that juice she said i
would never give you liquor i said why
not she said you're a preacher
i said how do you know that she said it
was obviously a preacher
i went to the next store right next door
to get the gum
the guy said come bishop
i'm getting irritated now why do you
call me that
he said but you look like one
all this began to happen when i
literally began to ask god
what i
what shirt
what suit
i'm not joking
what am i telling you
ask god
when you stand in front of those dresses
which one should i pick
forget beyonce ask god
forget little nas ask god
what shirt should i buy you know forget
whomever ask god how should i fix my
hair ask him i'm telling you if you
listen he'll tell you not that not that
i've seen women in church on high heels
so high
i said lord if she wanted to commit
suicide she can just jump off those
shoes
she doesn't need a building are you
following me just jump off those shoes
and she's dead the things are so high
so i
ask god
are you with me and the lord will direct
you he'll speak to your conscience
all right
god bless you
you